bonjour petite bande à ça va très bien
pourrais tu es venu sans sa petite fille
est-ce que pourquoi pas où aller je vais
même pas dans les boîtes j'amène pas
chez toi parce que tu bouffes gens
courent il paraît que tu l'emmènes sur
tous les plateaux de télé que tu lu la
lettre dans les loges c'est vrai tu vois
tu vois c'est vrai et alors ça fait mal
dès l'été avant et pendant combien de
temps tu vas là l'été
mais j'aurais pu tout le monde est apte
à sionards la première fois qu'on sait
passe alors dans la cloche de petites
bandas et à seurre masters reviennent
c'est quoi tu la plaine du bia ta fille
parce que je trouvais que c'était un
joli mot et puis que ça faisait des
souverains - boivent et pourquoi pas
parce qu'il en a ou b qui s'appelait
libya africa non en mois
ouais mais c'est la seule raison certes
appel ta fille du nom des mines
anciennes maîtresses de ton mari c'est
pas moi c'est très très bonne augure et
à vapeur quand elle ira à l'école que
les gens se moquent d'elle on n'a pas
l'italie va pas les folles pourquoi
parce que je suis opposé à l'école et
que ce qui va se passer
bannir pâle comme l'école n'est pas
obligatoire ah bon l'éducation est
obligatoire
le mali qu'on peut apprendre à écrire
parler comment grâce à moi tu sais que
tu sais j'ai parlé mais je suis terme
btan c'est vrai alors dit moi quand tu
as eu un cette espèce de traversée du
désert comme ça tu es parti aux indes et
tu as vraiment découvert le bouddhisme
ans était déjà à la fin de la traversée
joyent est déjà plein de sève
c'est mon tour évidemment l'arbre de
bouddha fleurus et je les ai été touché
par la grâce
j'ai trouvé que c'était une des rares
philosophie ésotérique tison mystique
qui a porté un sens à la vie à toutes
les questions qui m'ont en général pas
de réponse contre quand on ne trouve pas
là vraiment des réponses adéquates dans
la vie veut ni dans les bouquins de
sociologie à la dans une sainte entre 5
et 10 des couleurs le bouddhisme quinze
jours mais j'ai pas j'ai découvert
bouddhisme en quinze jours nadja on
apprend que quand même vous disant qu'un
jour je sais très bien que tu vas envie
non pas du tout on a le temps de
découvrir vous
quinze jours on n'a pas le temps de le
pratiquer les deux mythes devenu bon
bouddha qui beaucoup plus loin que moi
10h15 aussi d'ailleurs saisi dans la
dernière fois que je t'avais interviewé
tu m'avais inventé un truc assez fou je
tournais pas mal tu m'avais dit
finalement le vrai et crise s'était pas
jésus c'était judas parce que lui il
avait tout sacrifier il avait même
sacrifier son image légal et beaucoup
plus loin c'est une théorie très
intéressant qui est que en fait j'ai dit
cris n'est qu'un imposteur puisque
finalement c'est ducale beau rôle et que
le vrai christ c'est évidemment j date
us et 5,6 calme environ laissé pour tous
mais tu sais sans gitaï aurait pas le
trio donc lui appliquer la vigueur
non donc donc le christ et judas bien
syrie en plus son martyre durera la
chine qui compense convertir dur à
l'infini disent que t'es un sale au
poumon secondes pour toujours je vais
leur redire au moins bon il en a et il
en a vraiment eu mal pendant quelques
heures maintenant c'est terminé il est
au ciel je réside à chaque fois que ton
père newell quand on sera tous les deux
chez pas seul groupe fin quand je te
demanderai toujours raconter cette
vision et du biac que tu fais ton
l'argent je le dépense toujours des
actions de la compagnie électrique
belmont n'ont absolument pas de
l'affection que de vendre avec bien sûr
de garder gagné ou perdu jeudi dernier
les factions détail en belgique ça
marche ça marche est en tout cas
peut-être que tu sais si j'avais encore
des actions sont venus en train de
pleurer sur tes jours de la très plaisir
d'ailleurs le nom que tu fais pour leur
gendre de tout cet argent mais je le
dépense je ne dépends d'ailleurs pas que
pas que pour moi personnellement mais
j'aime dépenses en vidéo je dépense en
voyage je l'investis dépensant des tas
de choses comme ça tu sais on gagne ou
on gagne de l'argent
mais ce que je fais on demande beaucoup
aussi donc on est obligé comme ça donne
le jour j'aurai vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent de façon que ce soit
sexuelle production ou n'importe où je
me calme soleil et élèvent des enfants
qui ont faim ils au fardeau trouve comme
ça oui bien sûr je vous
faire d'autres j'ai indiqué en adopter
un bon tu vas m'a bouffé non j'avais
vraiment mauvaise car je m'étais acheté
une maison tu vas acheter une maison un
c4 d'acheter une maison et ce sera pas
moi se fringue société pas bon tu vas
l'etrat h&m fait très bien si c'est le
cas ce grand geste et les très grandes
banques avaient tué trip tu veux il ya
découvert jury car je t'en vas massa
mais mes victoires à ses frappes
ah bon j'adore on vous coupe les
méchantes com